how did I find a trustworthy manager
we're going to answer that question in
today's episode of lunch and earn so I
recently got asked the question for one
of my youtube audience love you guys
ixora who wrote in this day how did I
find a trustworthy manager so what is
referring to is for Toronto dance also i
made a video recently about this
business that i've recently taken over
and I hired somebody to come and help me
do all the operations and run the
business because I have a lot of
different things going on right now and
I wanted to have him on with me Alex
he's been on the channel a couple of
times already but alex is sick today
he's at home he's throwing up he's lying
down and so instead of Alex we have
Alex's girlfriend ruzanna who was a part
of the process as well and we're going
to talk about how this whole thing came
to be a couple of months ago I was
traveling with my best friend to Greece
and Armenia Alex start calling me in the
middle of the night and super excited he
told me about the offer from Evan you
know he had a job at the moment when I
haven't asked him to join TDs and run
the business I boy was a huge
responsibility first of all so my first
my first thought was like wow this is
big this is such a big responsibility
and I could never think about being part
of tds tes since then big has become
part of our life big part of our lives
like we spend so much time here every
day he wakes up it's all about you know
how excited he is about the business how
excited he is to run the school on
warfare Evan but anyway when he first
mentioned about the opportunity i was
awesome i thought it was a great idea
but i was a little worried about it
because he was in sales at the moment
and then switching from sales into
something that has a responsibility from
operations perspective from marketing it
was a very different word but since I
met alex and i met him in tds and he
always wanted to dance he was so
passionate about sauce and I always
believed that if you have the
opportunity to work in an area that you
love you'll be the luckiest person in
the or
of course there's a lot of challenges
there's a lot of things that you know
alex has to get to know and work but
every day he wakes up and he's so
excited to help the students make sure
that people are having fun to dancing
making sure that everything is running
well that I thought it was a great
challenge great opportunity i'm super
excited that alex has accepted it cool
so a couple things that I wanted to
share to add on to that one Toronto
that's also about is all about family
right are one word is family and so all
of the major hires that we make in the
school is people who are part of the
family so Alex started as a student and
then became a helper and it helped her
as an advanced student that comes back
to volunteer at the more entry level
classes so one of the most important
things for me when I'm hiring somebody
bringing someone aboard my team is a
personality right I need to know that I
can work with them that I can train them
that I can develop them and alex is
somebody who was also a friend right
like Alex hands-on have been friends for
a while and I had known Alex as being a
student in the classes and as a helper
interesting thing when I was sitting
down with the previous owner of the
business and we thinking okay who could
we have to come and run help run this
business Alex was one of the people that
we talked about and she met with Alex
and he had she turned it down he said
thank you so much really flattered but I
don't think it's a good fit for me and I
said no no so I gotta talk to Alex and
it may not be a fit but I thought it was
a really strong but now I had to have a
conversation with him and we had
multiple conversations leading up to it
in all of the my businesses wanna make
sure that people have a happy personal
life too and you know even though
Rosanna and Alex are not married yet you
know Alex come on get to work get to
work everybody in YouTube leave a
comment to tell Alex that he need to get
to work you know their relationship
means a lot to me and and having them be
happy with this too and at the time when
we had to make this decision Rosanna was
away
and I wanted to have a conversation with
her to to make sure that all of her
questions were answered and she was
comfortable with it and we ended up
connecting your arm skype in the middle
of our time in every in time but you
couldn't talk yes my family was sleeping
so I was typing and Evan was talking so
I was actually pretty awesome experience
and so in terms of finding managers I
think one is important to find somewhere
that you trust that you know that you
like it's not just about the skill set I
would actually rather hire somebody who
has the personality that I feel like I
can groom and give the skill set to the
skills can be learned and somebody like
Alex who likes to hustle who likes to
learn will get better even though we may
not have the skills yet you want to get
better and he'll get better a lot faster
than somebody who has the skills but it
has kind of checked out as a pathetic
right and then somebody who you can see
growing into a bigger role and I think
that was really important for me and
finding somebody who I already knew I
think it's easy to get lost in just
hiring people off of skills and off of a
resume and say add I need a programmer
great I'm going to hire that program
because they all the skills and you
start working together and it doesn't
work out and so find someone that you
know you'd like your trust I would even
suggest start on a small project first
what actually convinced me to work with
Alex I didn't think Alex would be a good
instructor for tds at the start that I
thought he had too much ego because when
he was in my level six class he would
all give me crap in that he didn't want
to take my advice right and he was a
friend and it so it's fine like great
but I thought Nino Alex I love him as a
guy but I don't think it'd be a good
instructor because dude can't take
feedback right but what happened was the
the current owner then wanted to make an
instruction set final on board I'll help
train him and she got sick and I had to
jump in and train him and in those
moments that's when he surprised me
initially what you under wanted me to do
was just I'll be at the front and give
him some opportunities and I said Alex
you know what I'm not gonna learn
anything being at the front teaching I
want you to go and do it if you're ready
and it was like the day of and he said
okay I'm gonna do it and I just threw
him in front of the class and he really
surprised me was how prepared he was how
energetic he was how yes he made
mistakes but we
quickly willing to fix them and work on
himself and that experience made me
comfortable insane man this guy when you
commit to something really goes all in
and really cares and so that little mini
project together made me comfortable to
really fight for him to become the
manager of school so the question we
have for you guys today is so this
question about Evans business came from
you guys and if you have another
question about his business please leave
it in the comments and we'll get back to
you mmm I like it if you have another
question about Toronto dance salsa leave
it below and I'll make a video response
thank you guys for watching continue to
believe and i'll see you soon